tanger le sujet tant seconde arthur qui
j'étais tellement démotivés j'avais
juste plus envie de rire il y a deux ans
un diagnostic de diabète de type 2 a
bouleversé le quotidien de nos valley ma
perception des choses qui est une jeune
de 15 16 ans ne devrait jamais comme
avoir à se piquer son voeu pour
s'injecter médicaments l'adolescente a
dû transformer sur votre devis dans
l'alimentation aérienne difficile pour
moi c'est sûrement là c'est vraiment
facile c'est c'est je veux gones de flou
sans veulent eux qui vraiment cessé
l'exercice physique qui peu difficile
parce que le corps nécessairement est
habitués mais aussi quand tu es juste
fatigué il y a vingt ans le diabète de
type 2 et est une maladie d'adultes
c'est une résistance à l'insuline qui
fait en sorte que les niveaux de ce que
montrent ans maintenant il ya plus de
diabète de type 2 chez les ados que de
ses parts à cause de l'épidémie
d'obésité et la consommation de calories
danse dont les sucres ajoutés
il y a deux types de diabète de type 1
liées à la génétique et qui touche les
enfants en bas âge et celui de type 2
est liée à l'embonpoint liées aux
habitudes de vie ces derniers et donc
nouveau chez les jeunes est en hausse
constante
et c'est sans compter les diabétiques
qui s'ignorent c'est vraiment inquiétant
parce que le pré diabète est une
condition qui augmente de façon
exponentielle chez les jeunes si on
regarde les données américaines
une des formes de pré-diabète qu'on a su
déceler augmenté de 4 +4 80% sur une
période de cinq ans c'est une maladie
qu'on dit silencieuse qui entraîne des
complications bien réel 13% des jeunes
qui la développe font de l'hypertension
et 80 % ont des problèmes de cholestérol
si on voit le pré diabète chez un jeune
de 12 ans et un diabète de type 2 frein
à 15 ans alors ça des impacts vraiment
majeur au niveau de la mortalité et la
morbidité dans glee maladie les
conséquences de cette maladie là à très
court terme pour des jeunes
mes collègues cardiologue me disent
qu'ils voient de plus en plus d'adultes
dans la trentaine qui font des infarctus
je pense qu'on n'a pas encore goûté
la quel est l'impact de cette
problématique majeure qui touche
l'enfant à sainte-justine on apprend aux
patients et aux familles à gérer le
diabète
peu importe le type nous apprennent à
surveiller les glycémies ils apprennent
tous les deux avoir des saines habitudes
de vie
les habitudes de vie ont bien changé
l'internet et les jeux vidéo ont rendu
nos loisirs plus sédentaires la
malbouffe à faire augmenter nos tour de
taille l'obésité et le diabète auront un
impact énorme sur notre système de santé
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal